un double vol et en corse pour les
dimensions du vélo un contrôle du poids
à nous avons un gabarit c'est à dire un
instrument plus fort mais qui donne les
cotes en ce qui concerne pas pour halak
centrale le pédalier le positionnement
de la selle le positionnement du guidon
et surtout des prolongateurs pour les
contre la montre
il ya des distances à ne pas dépasser et
puis il ya aussi des auteurs
éventuellement par rapport au guidon de
la mode à ne pas dépasser
tous ces positionnements la bon nous
contrôlons sens parce qu'une connexion
l'époque et ça permet de ne pas avoir
des positions des positions de pédalage
trop dangereuse par rapport à la
recherche du ray de la meilleure
pénétration dans l'air ça c'est le
premier et le deuxième point si nous
faisons la pesée des vélos
pourquoi parce que il faut savoir que
veut lui il a un poids minimum qui est
autorisé de 6 kg 8
donc on doit pouvoir faire derrière le
contrôle des vélos même sur autun pour
s'assurer mais comme on sait que la
cautionne dépend de beaucoup d'aléas on
ne fait pas obligatoirement les
contrôles sur ces vélos la met sur les
vélos contre la montre puisque tous tous
tuer la technologie peut aider à la
performance à ce niveau donc on est
particulièrement vigilant et on s'assure
donc les bleus ne font pas ce point
c'est d'ailleurs lors du contre la
montre
à fort de france on a eu l'occasion de
rencontrer deux vélos qui faisait moins
deux civils au but je savoir que c'est
lui c'est i derrière qui a dit parce que
vous savez après toutes les histoires et
julie baumann s'est dégradée qui y avait
une recherche de la performance à
travers la légèreté mais il y avait des
contretemps optique de danger parce
qu'un vélo trop léger c'est un vélo qui
reste dangereux pour le coureur
cela signifie que il est hyper fragile
ce vélo et cela signifie aussi qu'en cas
de devant le problème il est beaucoup
moins facilement maîtrisable